welcome to this video playing keno kind
kind from Iceland some Queens gambit to
150 rated okay so it started with this
triangle setup but we have transposed
into an quite classical looking Queens
gambit mmm YUM this isn't that this is
quite uncommon this only 94 yeah it's um
it's a stone wall set up don't know if
you go to your father's probably an easy
way to play like this and then then have
three yeah the question is some is each
five move maybe I should just play this
counter stone wall so this is a simple
way to proceed giving wider chances for
slide but very steady advantage I can
activate the bishop somewhat and it
still is a bad bishop potentially in all
kinds of end games
now I can play goddesses curious I'm not
quite sure why you would allow that I
just I just don't mind it all to
exchange all that and and game night
against bishop in any with Queens on
risk with Queens off would be a would be
good for me check yeah this is just a
winning endgame plain and simple i get i
get the passport here and this is no
valid majority because i have this night
proclaim locating sorry blockading the
pawns
that cannot defend that it's so is it a
win really or is it just a baguette no
that's probably a win would be strange
if it wasn't then the Jeep on should be
too much but at the moment this Bishop
only eight prevents me from easily
advancing hmm how to how to play this g5
yeah I'm not sure that this is helpful
well but probably probably Anita now I'm
wondering about be five if i should i
should play that
hmm it's probably not helping
hmm yeah it's a bit more difficult than
I've then I expected probably I need to
reroute it to our phone get rid of the
king of locating piece
okay okay no but but now i can i can
switch over to our form check this is
very helpful let's now i have the the
entry route by 85 okay so yeah just here
and then jen then be five
no I can I can just I could just enter
now running all the way to be seventh
it's all so glamorous resigned yeah i
was i was pretty sure that white should
win the endgame but right here I wasn't
I wasn't entirely sure if he doesn't
give up if you just retreats let's say
to see a diff I'm I'm winning then now
the computer actually gives us that
equal oh maybe I had something wrong I
mean this should be really enough to win
the game this the same disposition but
maybe I spoiled it right here I was I
was not a happy 5s Winningham be five
wins yeah the computers are just just
deadly in this position ah very nice
yeah he a minute sir this is this is
this is actually the point of course I
saw that c6 takes I only thought about
taking with the pawn but of course I can
just take with the night and this is
this is the point there's this idea also
and a7 hanging so b5 was the key move so
I was pretty sure that white must win
here but I didn't find the right way be
five wins okay now and this is the new
mistake where this again losses okay
yeah this is also it's pretty obviously
bad because I get get the King into the
game so he must keep keep the bishop
here in fact the computer gives a six
but I am ok a six probably two to
prevent anybody
five ideas yeah I thought that maybe
this was was a way to proceed just push
the Jeep all of the computer says it's
just a draw and I was add this in my tea
in this kind of position and I thought
okay for the porn I have a big
compensation and maybe I get get this
invasion going but the computer says hi
you're not invading it looks terrible
for black but maybe it's not a win if
the computer gifts it gives us a 0 0 0
at 0 at death 34 then this is a draw it
simply calculates to the end yeah funny
this looks so very tricky for black but
it seems that for instance this kind of
line simply doesn't win check know when
I can never really lose but it seems so
there's two two little material left
this was my idea with 92 dislodging the
king and then entering with my own king
but ok what I've here to recognize is
that in this type of position I have the
night recapture this is very important I
didn't see that yeah but I think an
interesting endgame and in general I
mean if you if you have this kind of
Jack structural disadvantage of a bishop
against the night it's not such a great
idea to trade to open up and trade or
lose I really welcomed this end game it
says it's clearly better for me can't
the way it it went down it was even it
was even winning alright thanks for
watching